ever since america was created in 1776
new york has symbolized the american
dream people from all over the world
would immigrate through ellis island
hoping to create a new life in new york
city
over time this made nyc the heartland of
america as the city became the home of
banks brokerages hedge fund exchanges
and basically every other financial
institution you can think of we also saw
the rise of broadway and carnegie hall
which have made the state the dream
destination for aspiring artists as well
despite this rich history new york
hasn't been doing all that well over the
past few decades
in fact new york is the fastest drinking
state in the us in terms of population
in 2021 alone new york suffered a net
population loss of 1.58
which was nearly twice the population
loss of second place this translates to
a population decline of over 300 000
people aside from people fleeing the
state in masses many have started to
associate new york with old world
corruption lobbying and deception so
what happened to new york
starting off with the most obvious
reason we have the insanely high cost of
living now i'm sure you've all heard
about this but it's hard to visualize
just how bad it is without some concrete
numbers so let's dive into some data
also i should mention that most of the
data that we'll be looking at will be
regarding new york city nearly half the
state lives in this one city and it's by
far the number one place that people
think of when they think new york with
that being said it let's take a look at
nyc housing right now the median sale
price of single-family homes townhouses
and condos in nyc comes in at just over
eight hundred thousand dollars given
that the median income in the city is
just over forty one thousand dollars the
average house cost nearly twenty times
the median income even if we look at
household in gamma we only get sixty
seven thousand dollars meaning that the
average house costs 12 times the median
household income this makes
homeownership basically impossible for
the average person or family in nyc and
that's why most people don't even
consider buying a property in the city
usually most of them just rent for their
entire lives and given that real estate
ownership is responsible for creating 90
of all millionaires in the world this is
not the best of signs for the people of
nyc to make things worse and it's not
like renting is that much cheaper a
studio apartment itself will cost you 3
638 per month on average that translates
to over 43 000 per year which is higher
than the median annual income in the
city and that's just a studio if you
want a one bedroom you're looking at
four thousand seven hundred sixty one
dollars per month or fifty seven
thousand dollars per year if you want a
two bedroom you're looking at six
thousand one hundred and eighty eight
dollars per month or seventy four
thousand dollars per year and if you
want a three bedroom you're looking at
six thousand five hundred forty four
dollars per month or 78 000 per year
obviously none of these options are
affordable for the average resident in
nyc
i mean the rent for a two bedroom
apartment is literally a thousand
dollars more expensive than the mortgage
and tax that you would have to pay for
an 800 000 house if you could afford
this by yourself you might as well just
buy a house most people in nyc can't
afford it and that's why almost all of
the average folks have roommates in fact
40 of all adult renters in new york live
with roommates aside from having to
share your apartment and still pay
insane amounts in rent you also have to
deal with extremely old buildings the
average residential building in nyc is
literally 90 years old this not only
makes these buildings dingy and
depressing but they're usually infested
with mice rants and cockroaches and all
of that is just a housing situation
almost every facet of life is just as
expensive in nyc
groceries for example cost 486 dollars
per person per month on average the
average across the us is only 348 or 30
lower hearing all this i don't think
you'd be surprised to hear the 60 of new
yorkers live paycheck to paycheck
clearly the living situation for the
average new yorker isn't anything to
brag about and this has prompted many to
ditch the state
historically one of the top reasons that
people immigrated to nyc was because of
all the job opportunities that are
available in the city no other city in
the world offered the same networking
capabilities when it came to the
financial markets or hustling your way
to the top with the rise of technology
over the past few decades however the
appeal of nyc has been on a decline take
the stock market for example before 2000
the trading floor of the new york stock
exchange was crucial to operating the
stock market but with the rise of the
nasdaq and electronic trading and
execution trading forests have basically
become obsolete you no longer need to be
in new york to make it in the financial
world in fact most of the fintech
companies that we hear about nowadays
weren't even created in new york this
includes robin hood coinbase square
allied bank acorn stripe and so many
more
and if you don't have to be in new york
to build a financial career why put up
with all the cons that come along with
the region
also something else to note is that you
no longer have to be involved in the
financial markets at all to even become
wealthy 50 to 100 years ago the most
straightforward way to earn a high
salary was to go to new york join a
financial firm and work up the corporate
ladder but now there's an industry that
not only pays more but is also less
intense and less stressful and that's of
course tech
nowadays the dream career for many is to
get a job at fang or an up-and-coming
startup and this makes sense given how
much these companies pay i'm sure you've
all heard about software engineers
making multiple six figures but nowadays
top software engineers can even earn
seven figures now to google for instance
even if you're just an entry-level
software engineer you earn a total
compensation of 191 000
meanwhile if you work up to being a
principal engineer you can earn a total
compensation of 1.08 million dollars
we can see an extremely similar
compensation plan at facebook as well
even if you're just an entry-level
software engineer you earn a total
compensation of 184 000
meanwhile if you work update being a
principal engineer you can earn up to
1.61 million dollars now of course
working up to principal engineer is no
easy task but it's also rather
achievable if you stick with your
company for 20 to 30 years
also even if you don't make it to level
8 and you get stuck at level 6 or 7
you're still pulling in well over half a
million dollars per year and that's in
today's dollars by the time most of us
reach our 50s and 60s these positions
themselves will likely be paying well
over a million dollars so finance is no
longer the only way to make big money
without starting a business not to
mention while these tech jobs are by no
means easy you probably won't be working
80 to 100 hours per week either like
investment bankers and hedge fund people
you'll probably be working closer to 60
hours which makes tech jobs even more
appealing so the rise of tech has robbed
new york of much of its wall street
appeal
aside from a high cost of living and
deteriorating appeal a major drawback of
nyc is that it has never really been a
final destination a lot of people are
attracted to the city by its fast life
and career opportunities but more times
than not these people don't intend to
stay for the rest of their lives the
vast majority of individuals who are
immigrating to new york can usually be
categorized into two bins the queer
builders and the adventurers the career
builders usually go their straight out
of college or they might even go there
for college itself these guys usually
get a job at a financial firm or
consulting firm or they might even start
their own company then they grind out
most of their 20s in nyc and end up
saving multiple six figures if not even
seven figures and finally they move back
to their home city or an up and coming
suburb where they get a job as a
financial analyst or an accountant and
start a family meanwhile the adventurers
are broke throughout their entire
twenties but they get the satisfaction
that they lived their life to the
fullest while they were still young and
free however these guys also usually end
up moving to suburbs as they grow older
in other words nyc is rarely a final
destination and this makes sense given
the pros and cons of the city while the
city offers great career opportunities
and a fast life it's not exactly the
best place to raise a family cities in
general usually don't have great public
schools because they don't get very good
funding in fact schools in urban
districts get 2 100 less per student
than schools in suburban districts
considering this it's not surprising
that parents are usually reluctant to
send kids to public schools in major
cities even if you find a good school
the environment itself is usually not
the best for kids crime rates are high
subways aren't the safest and there's no
neighborhood swimming pool or park and
this is especially problem if you're
living in poorer areas of the city
aside from it being hard to raise a
family new york isn't the best place to
settle down as an individual either
first of all the weather is pretty bad
winters are often brutal given that new
york receives the seventh most amount of
snowfall in the entire country this is
the exact opposite of california
californians often say that weather is
one of the top reasons that they want to
stay in california but maybe they're
overstating this advantage given that
people have been moving to new york for
centuries despite its bad weather
anyway aside from poor weather you also
have taxes that will make you poor state
income taxes range from 4 up to 10.9
combine this with federal income taxes
and high cost of living and you'll be
broke before you know it while this may
be an acceptable sacrifice throughout
your 20s this gets old real fast as you
grow older and sooner or later most
people just want something more slow
paced and relaxed which usually leads
them to suburbs
in the end nyc has historically been one
of the most desirable cities in the
world
people from all around the world have
been immigrating to the city since the
beginning of america and there's still
plenty of people moving to city to build
their careers and lives but over the
past several years the number of people
leaving the city and state has outpaced
a number of people moving to the state
you could list a slew of reasons for
this from bad weather to poor schools
but at the end of the day it just comes
down to one reason less and less people
think that the opportunities offered by
new york are worth the high cost
nowadays you can progress within the
financial world without having to live
in new york not to mention it you don't
even have to join the financial world to
make large salaries anymore technology
and the internet have created more
hyping opportunities than ever before
the fact that the billionaire's list and
the fortune 500 are dominated by tech is
simply perfect evidence of this this
isn't to say that new york is gonna fall
towards irrelevancy or something like
that new york is still filled with
plenty of career opportunities some of
which are still unique to new york like
consulting also there's a lot of young
souls who still want to have an
adventure in new york before they settle
down in a regular old suburb so while
new york is the fastest drinking state
right now this is just natural shifts
due to changing opportunities sooner or
later new york will settle down at a new
population level which will likely help
with over congestion and affordability
and hopefully this will open up the
state to a whole new generation of
people but that's just what i think
would you live in new york comment that
down below
also drop a like if you're all about the
chosen bourbon life and of course
consider checking out our discord
community to just for your video ideas
and consider subscribing and see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm hari and i'll see you guys on
the next one
you